ja vorweg als ich Volontär war bei WELT
am SONNTAG da war gab es einen tollen
Chefredakteur und der Chefredakteur der
hieß Klaus Jacobi und der hatte eine
tolle Kolumne die ist das Narrenschiff
leider ist doch sehr Kubi verstorben vor
einigen Jahren aber das Narrenschiff ist
Segel fröhlich weiter und zwar mit
Volldampf über die Berliner See an Bord
zahlreiche leichtmatrosinnen und zwar
vorne weg die Grünen Beispiele gibt es
zu Hause die Grünen die uns täglich mit
Belehrungen kommen über Veggie days und
die absolut saubere Landwirtschaft
sitzen fröhlich beim Oktoberfest
beieinander hingestellt von Ricarda lang
Claudia Roth und Katharina Schulze
Vorsicht drei Maßkrüge und eine große
schlachterplatte nach dem Motto für uns
das Fleisch für euch die Moral aber
Robert Habeck haben wir gerade drüber
gesprochen verstarb dich das
Energieunternehmen Juniper lässt uns
tagelang glauben dass die gasumlage
nicht kommt
und dann muss er zugeben sie kommt doch
sonst fehlen 35 Milliarden Euro
irgendwie und die will auch nicht
Christian Lindner bezahlen aber warum
ist wirklich ist das kann er nicht
flüssig vertreten und auch erklären
stattdessen brüllte die Opposition im
Bundestag nieder das ist keine Politik
das ist reine Panik mein Eindruck ist
dass ein Teil der Regierung komplett
abgehoben ist nach nur einem Jahr im Amt
und völlig den Boden unter den Füßen
verloren hat
weitere Beispiele in den Zügen und in
der immer noch im Flugzeugen der
Lufthansa und den Zügen der Deutschen
Bahn wo der Staat der Aigner ist gilt
maskenpflicht ja aber Robert Habeck und
Olaf Scholz fliegen fröhlich nach Kanada
und der eine lässt sich auch noch über
sein Instagram Account fröhlich
freundlich fotografieren ohne Maske weil
Masken gelten für die da oben nicht so
kommt es dann auch in der Begründung für
uns hier unten schon wir hier oben ihr
da unten das ist die Botschaft die sich
da verbreitet
sie lassen sich hier in hochglänzenden
E-Autos durch Berlin kutschieren und
nehmen schon mal so die Energiewende
fahren nur weg während wir uns fragen wo
soll denn der Strom herkommen für alle
E-Autos die wir künftig fahren sollen
und wer soll die in den bezahlen
bitteschön von den Ladesäulen die nicht
da sind ganz zu schweigen einer noch
Photovoltaik seit der Stadt Gasheizung
ist das neue Ding beschäftigt sich man
ernsthaft damit dann findet man heraus
dass sich eine
Photovoltaikanlage nach den geltenden
Regeln auf einem Einfamilienhaus nach 18
Jahren rechnet nach 20 Jahren also zwei
Jahre später nachdem sich gerechnet hat
ist sie Schrott also da gibt es viele
viele Unwegbarkeiten das Narrenschiff
auf voller Fahrt ich fordere Schluss mit
dieser Scheinheiligkeit kommt zurück auf
den Boden und seht zu dass sie die
wirklichen Probleme wirklich regelt
Klang jetzt fast wie eine Rede für die
linke Partei da würde ich Frau Wagen
gehe ich direkt gerne mal fragen ob sie
sich als Parteimitglied aufnehmen
möchtest
und das weiß ich gar nicht Alter wir
sehen uns sehr einig aber das Problem
ist also was ich mich frage ist
selbstverständlich muss die Politik
ihren Job machen aber was findest du
denn falsch daran wenn auch eine Ricarda
lang mal im Privatleben abschaltet auf
dem Oktoberfest gar nicht überhaupt
nicht aber es kommt ja daher erstmal ist
es eine politische Botschaft in die
Grünen wollen natürlich in Bayern klar
machen wir haben auch Brauchtum das
wollen sie machen sie seit 20 Jahren
sehr erfolgreich wir haben Brauchtum wir
sind eine bayerische Partei wir nehmen
auch die Bräuche war aber wer sich so
politisch dieses zu nutzen macht muss
natürlich auch in Kauf nehmen dass alles
was er macht und tut politisiert wird
und in diesem Fall ist das so wenn ich
da eine fette schlachterplatte vor mir
habe und gleichzeitig erkläre die
Landwirtschaft muss darauf achten dass
sie nicht zu viel schlachtet dann wird
das Oktoberfest doch gerade von
Tierschützern kritisiert weil der
angeblich ich weiß nicht wie wird
zigtausende Ochsen jedes Jahr für
geschlachtet werden unglaublich viele
Hühner da sind ja die animal rights
Watcher dabei und zu sagen die haben
sogar Straße
weil man Vegetarier ist nein man darf
aber man muss die Botschaft Leben wie
man auch tatsächlich dann auch
verbreitet und man kann nicht beides
machen man kann natürlich nach Kanada
fliegen aber Jürgen Trittin zum Beispiel
nur ein Beispiel hat vor vielen Jahren
als Minister das natürlich verinnerlicht
und hat als er mal zu einem Umweltgipfel
nach Brasilien geflogen ist Zertifikate
gekauft oder kaufen lassen von seinem
Ministerium hier dann eingesetzt hat zur
Reduzierung des Abgang ist es nicht weil
es zumindest dass ein Ausgleich schafft
aber besser als ich setze mich da ich
bin für ein Veggie day gegen die
Schlachterei von Tieren lass die
fröhlich protestieren die Grünen
Sympathisant und setz mich damit der
schlachterplatte und mach hoch die
Tassen auf dem Oktoberfest das passt
auch wirklich nicht zusammen auch die
Heuchelei in der Politik ja das ist ja
einfach Doppelmoral also auch in anderer
Hinsicht ich meine ich finde das toll
dass es wieder ein Oktoberfest gibt und
ich finde es auch wunderbar dass ich die
Leute da einfach wieder normal bewegen
weil das was Corona mal war mit den
ersten Virusvarianten das ist eben
vorbei also alle anderen Länder oder
alle anderen Länder haben ja jetzt auch
gesagt Corona Amerika hat sie jetzt auch
Kampagne beendet aber wir haben halt ein
verrückten Gesundheitsminister der ja
daran festhält dass die Pandemie nicht
vorbei ist und wir sind durchaus nicht
davor gefeit dass Kinder in den Schulen
wieder gequält werden irgendwelche
Masken zu tragen oder ständige Tests zu
machen wir haben diese
ffp2-maskenpflicht in Schuhe Entzügen
beschlossen also wir also ich nicht aber
der Bundestag was ja völlig verrückt ist
ich meine im Flieger übrigens nicht also
die die sich fliegen leisten können Sie
brauchen ab September keine Maske mehr
und die die also mit dem Zug fahren ich
meine das ist ja Killer Programm für die
für die Zug also und das machen grüne
die immer sagen wir müssen noch den
öffentlichen Verkehr und Zug und um
Gottes Willen nicht Flügen nicht fliegen
also das ist vorn und hinten ganz
verlogen und bei der Energiepolitik ja
ähnlich ich meine wir importieren jetzt
unglaublich teures aber auch unglaublich
dreckig ist aber Politiker früher anders
das ist ja die ganze Zeit sicherlich
immer Politiker gegeben die unehrlich
waren und es hat sich ja auch immer auch
Korruption und alles mögliche gegeben
aber ich glaube die Ausmaße ja die sind
schon mehr geworden also dieses auch
dieser geestos dass man der Meinung ist
man muss das Volk irgendwie erziehen
also das finde ich ja sogar dann
unerträglich wenn man sich selber dran
hält also ich meine ich habe überhaupt
nichts dagegen ich kenne unheimlich
sympathische Menschen die sind
Vegetarier oder Veganer und das ist ja
auch völlig in Ordnung was ich nicht
ausstehen kann obwohl sie auch das
Fleisch verzichten
jeder soll das machen wie er will aber
was ich wirklich nicht ausstehen kann
wenn dann einer sozusagen mich versucht
zu erziehen oder mir irgendwie das zu
vermeiden was ich esse und was natürlich
ganz heuchlerisch ist ist dann noch das
was er andere beschrieben hat also wenn
man selber nicht macht und dann aber
sozusagen nach draußen und ich meine da
kommt ja auch noch eine soziale
Komponente dazu ich glaube das ist auch
in vielen Debatten etwas was die Leute
wirklich furchtbar verärgert also wenn
sich die dann im E-Wagen herumfahren
auch noch für die besseren Menschen
halten weil sie sich halt zum Beispiel
einen tollen Tesla leisten können und
der der jetzt zum Beispiel wo ich wohne
auf dem Dorf mit seinem Diesel
Mittelklassewagen rumfährt weil er weil
da fährt auch nichts anderes und jetzt
sich Sorgen macht wieder die Schnitt
Sprit noch bezahlt der wird ja nicht nur
sozial jetzt nach unten gedrückt so es
wird ja sogar eine öffentliche Platte
noch so getan guter selber schuld was
fährt er damit seinem Diesel kann sich
doch auch ein Tesla leisten also habe
ich wirklich manchmal das Gefühl so wie
damals Marie antoniet also was
beschweren Sie sich wenn Sie das Brot
wenn Sie das Brot nicht mehr bezahlen
können ja dann sollen sich doch Kuchen
kaufen und sollen sie Kuchen essen also
das ist eine Arroganz und das ist eine
Abgehobenheit die natürlich für die
Demokratie ein großes Problem ist weil
wir haben es gibt ja immer mehr Menschen
die aus gutem Grund auch sagen
diese Regierung oder auch manchmal
manche sagen ja auch die gesamte Politik
die wissen ja gar nicht wie es uns geht
und sie wenden sich dann ab und ich
meine das Wesen in der Demokratie ist ja
dass Menschen politische Ansprechpartner
haben dass sie sagen okay die vertragen
man hier einmal Herrn Frank herr Frank
haben Sie denn das Gefühl dass die
Politik sie erziehen möchte ja natürlich
das erleben wir schon seit 20 30 Jahren
das Problem ist einfach dass dieser
Moralismus der immer nur in Schwarz und
Weiß einteilt in gutem Böse im Prinzip
auf Lebenslügen passiert ja ein kleines
Beispiel ich meine ich kann natürlich
sagen ein ein Fleischesser bringt Tiere
um aber es macht ein Brotesser genauso
wir müssen die Tiere auf dem Feld töten
mit Chemie oder mit Biolandbau mit mit
Schwermetallen also es gibt nicht diese
schuldlose Ernährung es gibt gute
Kompromisse es gibt Qualität oder ich
kann sagen eine eine Tomate aus dem
Biolandbau ist toll finde ich auch toll
aber sie hat eine schlechtere Ökobilanz
wie aus wie die hollandtomate das heißt
wir brauchen die Fähigkeit weg von der
Moral über Qualität zu diskutieren und
da sehe ich aber jetzt ein großes
Problem weil man hat sich dermaßen in
diesem oralismus reingesteigert und hat
dermaßen auch Leute Scharen hinter sich
geschadet die jetzt das Einfordern und
nicht als die besseren fühlen das ist
jetzt also kritisch wird wenn man sich
da in der Öffentlichkeit sachlich äußert
und das merkt man auch daran dass diese
Menschen die dann versuchen Sachwissen
reinzubringen zu sagen ob das ist nicht
so schwarz und weiß die werden brutal
ausgegrenzt ja und dann in die Rechtecke
gestellt und dergleichen klimaleugner
und oder oder was immer das dann auch
heißt und das macht mir dann schon
Sorgen und wenn jetzt zum Beispiel auch
jetzt wenn es uns eingemacht geht und
wir kriegen jetzt ein Energieproblem und
die Leute frieren und die Leute gehen
pleite und sie gehen auf die Straße dann
zieht man jetzt plötzlich dass
diesen Winter vermutlich noch drüber
aber genau aber was man jetzt zum
Beispiel macht jetzt bringt man beim
plötzlich einen Schlagwort mit einem
rechts das zieht ja nicht mehr so fast
schon eine Auszeichnung wenn man es
rechts bezeichnet wird also das ist
wirklich lächerlich aber jetzt heißt es
delegitimierer des Staates was ist das
denn ja und ich mache mir langsam Sorgen
dass dieser Moralismus statt dass die
Leute mal wie sie hoffen wo ich euch
auch hoffe dass man zu Besinnung kommen
noch eine Schippe drauflegen und die das
Zungen zum Totalitarismus aufmachen ja
nein wir müssen wieder von diesem
moralistischen hohen Ross runter ein
bisschen die Wirklichkeit mal gucken
diskutieren und gute Lösungen finden und
wir sind da an so einem Weg der mir so
ein bisschen Sorgen macht Herr Stöhr sie
sind ja auch in der DDR aufgewachsen
nehmen sie denn schon Tendenzen wahr ja
ich war ja lange nicht in Deutschland
gewesen über 30 Jahren im Ausland
Frankreich Schweiz USA wieder Schweiz
und habe mich natürlich auch dort mit
den Lebensumständen vertraut gemacht und
ich glaube schon dass er sich war der
erstaunt als ich wieder kam und sah
diese beiden Dinge auch die
moralisierende Seite die mich ein
bisschen auch an das erinnert was ich in
meiner Jugend und Kindheit erlebt habe
aber auch die andere Seite dass man
natürlich seine
deine Worte auch leben muss dass man in
bestimmten Kompass braucht der für das
Leben entscheidend ist an dem man sich
richtet und egal ob der Wind von links
oder rechts weht seine Standards hat man
und die muss man dann einhalten und dazu
stehen und das wird natürlich jetzt
immer schwieriger weil die Politiker
natürlich immer stärker im Rampenlicht
stehen immer stärker natürlich gesehen
werden es gibt die sozialen Medien und
da kann man es sich einfach nicht
leisten solche Doppelmoral danach außen
zu repräsentieren das wird auf der einen
Seite glaube ich für jemanden
Öffentlichkeit steht immer schwieriger
und wichtiger sich an deine Standards zu
halten und genau das zu leben was man
sagt und auf der anderen Seite ist es
dann natürlich so dass man auch viel
viel mehr Druck aushalten muss und dann
auch dabei zu bleiben ich beneide nicht
die Politiker die unter diesen mit Druck
stehen wie habe ich und andere das ist
schon eine erhebliche Sache und viele
würden dann die Flinte ins Korn werfen
und ich hoffe dass die Politiker das
nicht machen aber ich hoffe auch dass
sie wahrnehmen dass es sehr wichtig ist
dass man eben zu seinen Worten steht und
dann seine Worte auch leben muss Billa
wir haben eben schon angesprochen
Politiker von früher man neigt ja immer
zu diesem früher war alles besser gibt
es denn Politiker die dir jetzt
einfallen zu denen du deine Teesorte
nicht gebracht hättest die sich an das
gehalten haben was Sie gesagt haben und
nicht geheuchelt haben ja was ihr neu
ist ist dieser moralische Rigorismus der
ja mit dem holt und der auch in Teilen
der Gesellschaft eingefordert wird also
ich muss ja moralisch mich überhöhen
damit ich eine Position vertrete Sie
haben darüber gesprochen das ist in der
Wissenschaft so das ist aber auch in der
Politik so dass es auch im Journalismus
so also dieser Haltung zeigen gehört
jetzt unglaublich dazu nur im Grunde
wird noch alles politischer ich überlege
gerade während ich rede wenn ich dir
dann nennen kann wir haben hier ein paar
eingeblendet für dich Konrad Adenauer
Willy Brandt
Helmut Schmidt kommt auch noch hier
haben wir jetzt Kennedy also jeder von
den hat natürlich seine seine seine
großen Highlights und jeder von denen
hat seine auch etwas dunkleren Seiten
konrad-adenauer hat als junger Politiker
mal sehr viel Geld weg spekuliert und
das ganze Vermögen an der Börse die SPD
ausspioniert haben in Deutschland auch
aber er hat auf jeden Fall sehr viel
Geld spekuliert und da hat ein Bankier
von der Deutschen Bank muss man leider
sagen dann gefunden der ihm das auf
Weise wieder ersetzt hat dieses Geld der
wurde auch sein Chef Berater später dann
in Zeiten das war als Kölner
Oberbürgermeister noch und später war er
ja dann Bundeskanzler der Mann blieb ihm
dann erhalten also Helmut Schmidt ist ja
tatsächlich dann auch so von Oskar lafon
10 damals mit den mit der Eigenschaft
erblickt worden nicht wer sowas fordert
eben diese sekundär Tugenden der können
auch ein KZ führen hatte natürlich sein
Köfferchen zu tragen als ehemaliger
Wehrmachtsoffizier aber hat natürlich
Deutschland mit unglaublicher stark und
Härte durch die größten Krisen geführt
die aber trotzdem wird kein von denen
jetzt nennen und sagen Helmut schmeißt
auf jeden Fall und
auch immer man muss ja die
Lebensleistung sehen ich will auch
jemand nennen trotz der schwarzen Kassen
fragt man sich ob sie überhaupt gegeben
hat dann Helmut Kohl ja weil die über
ihr Leben lang natürlich bestimmte Ziele
verfolgt haben und sie dann aber auch im
entscheidenden Moment entsprechend
durchgesetzt haben und deswegen würde
ich die beiden nennen mir fallen sicher
auch noch andere ein Willy Brandt hat
natürlich eine große Lebensleistung
hatte auch schwierige Phasen aber das
sind natürlich historische
Personen die sich im Nachhinein
natürlich auch ein bisschen erklären ob
Frau Wagenknecht schneller jemand
einfällt der den Ansprüchen genügen
würde heute oder auch einer von denen
die eingeblendet wurden ich meine ich
kenne ihn ja quasi nur als Kind und aus
der Geschichte aber Willy Brandt ist für
mich jemand der wirklich sehr
authentisch eine Position hatte seine
seine Haltung zu vielen Fragen nicht vor
sich hergetragen hat moralisch
aufgeblasen aber ich meine der hatte ja
auch eine Biografie ich meine es war
Emigrant ist vor den Nazis geflohen hat
dann eben in der SPD ja auch einen
wechselvolle Geschichte gemacht gehabt
bevor er dann eben auch wirklich
Bundeskanzler werden konnte und hat dann
Reformen durchgesetzt die finde ich sehr
sehr wichtig waren hat auch diese neue
Ostpolitik meine das war ja zu seiner
Zeit als wir die ersten Pipeline auch
damals mit der Sowjetunion aufgemacht
haben das nur dabei und er war ja auch
immer der Meinung wenn man also bei
allen Unterschieden und ich meine die
damalige soweit und war ja ein wirklich
nicht das Modell was irgendwie Willy
Brandt erfreulich fand dass man mit
wirtschaftlicher Zusammenarbeit am
ehesten noch irgendwo auch ein
Gesprächsfaden hält also ich finde das
ist schon jemand der eine sehr
authentische und und auch sehr
integro-politik gemacht hat das heißt
nicht dass da jetzt vielleicht nicht in
irgendeinem Winkel auch irgendwas war
was man finden kann aber er hat er stand
für das was er auch vertreten hat man
hatte nicht das Gefühl der erzählt
irgendwas und wenn er abends unter den
seinen ist lacht er sich halb tot über
das was er da eigentlich verbreitet hat
und bei heutigen Politikern ist das eben
teilweise wirklich anders